pop quiz hotshot you're in Harlem and
you're at this building you go through
the door enter the security code take
the elevator to the third floor knock on
this door where Rudy greets you hi and
welcome you make your way into a packed
apartment and try to find a seat what do
you get you get a live jazz performance
like no other
every Sunday Marjorie Elliot and her son
Rudel drear's
open the doors to their apartment for
people to come and listen to jazz music
we decided to use our apartment because
we can do what we want here it's just a
matter of this is home
so everybody who walks through that door
we treat his family and it's a pretty
big family the concerts are so popular
that if you're not on time finding a
seat can be a little tricky we fill up
the living room the kitchen hallway
people will stand out taking videos it's
pretty much like that every Sunday now
you know it's like it's jam-packed
the jazz concerts began in 1993 after
rudel's brother Phil passed away well my
brother passed away on a Sunday and
Mommy has a great idea to honor him with
concerts on Sundays you know when you
play music you just get all your angst
out and then it's just a healing feeling
so I think our thing was you know what
better way to honor him and with the
concert and we've been blessed to never
Evans to Sunday with their commitment
and consistency to play every Sunday the
concerts are now considered legendary in
Harlem attracting audiences from all
over the world
hey Rudel do you mind if we ask some of
the audience members where they came
from
of course I'm from Germany France
Australia yeah that's pretty cool I
think once we started it just took on a
life force of its own sometimes people
come and they just they don't know what
they're gonna expect you know it's like
rang a bell and get free jazz and then
once they get here and they have that
experience it's kind of something they
won't forget
for some people this is their church you
become here and I feel renewed and we
feel renewed and you never know when
you're going to touch out there so
you're putting out good energy it's
gonna work